regardless of the number of the people  who died I think people should take time  to mourn but at the same time opening  the Christmas market there's a good  opportunity for for things to normalize  and for for the Christmas spirit to  continue we should feel power when we  are all together fighting against that  that problem and I wouldn't say that we  should somehow stop our celebrations  stop our movements stop our why  nothing's fast and so on nutritious gone  of espacio of course what happened here  is horrible but you can't let it bring  everything to a standstill for me it's a  sense of compassion for the victims but  it's also my identification with the  city that makes me feel Berlin must  carry on and shouldn't lose its  character or its spirit of openness